the best thing you can do
is to take care of your own health and
the health of people around you
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
the absolute delight in speaking with
sergey young a longevity investor and
visionary with a mission to extend
healthy lifespans of 1 billion people
sergey founded the longevity vision fund
to achieve this and to accelerate life
extension technological breakthroughs
and to make longevity affordable and
accessible to all
i hope you enjoy our conversation
so hi sergey thank you very much for
joining me today and welcome to the
shiki science show
hi elena i'm very excited to be here
with you today thank you very much um so
my first question is um can you tell me
a bit more about your background and how
did you end up finding the longevity
vision fund and becoming a longevity
investor
yeah so two things here one
we all start to develop our interest or
uh you know go on our longevity and
health journey um
usually from our personal health crisis
so i ha i had my and it's like 80 or 90
of people whom i know exactly well it's
happened the same way significant
deterioration of your health or the
health of the people when you laugh
and then you start the oh my goodness
there's this thing you know taking care
of my health and longevity and i i need
to sort it out somehow so that was my
case as well it was not that dramatic
back in 2014 i discovered i have high
cholesterol level and i had a choice to
live on stadiums like on drug every day
till the rest of my life or you know try
to change this through lifestyle
interventions and i i i'm so happy i
choose the second path
and it was so successful like my level
of energy level of health um
desire to leave also change completely
in the course of six months so do i you
know my cholesterol level as well
decrease quite substantially and i
started to share it with people and that
it was so successful i saved so many
lives just by you know pushing people to
do their annual medical screening and uh
some of them discovered cancer because
it was early death they um
uh they managed to go through that they
they fully recovered and the quality of
the their lives sustained so uh i
thought well
this is something i can do for the world
and so i decided to
support scientists and entrepreneurs who
are working in the field of longevity
research or technology development and
uh i started with
longevity vision fund and
this is not my money it's money of
investors who trust me and our
scientific and um
investment team but it was such an
amazing experience like every year we're
looking at at least 200 companies
who'd uh who are working in the field of
human
health span and lifespan extension uh
and it's so it's it's been brilliant
experience and it feels really good so
we've been able to support 18 companies
uh through longevity vision fund and 18
uh scientific and entrepreneurial uh
teams and they bringing to this world
much more data-driven technology-based
version of healthcare
awesome and so out of these different
companies um are there are they biased
towards uh different areas or um i mean
is there some of them mainly
pharmaceutical based or others more uh
the basic science are there's more
looking at insurance or like what kind
of scope does it cover
yeah so um
the nature of investments is always
about diversification
so unlike right research when you like
pick up your theme and then you're just
working you know to develop you go very
deep into that so
um
every investment portfolio needs to be
diversified so your bets uh should be um
you know done in a different direction
so what are the directions that we're
using for longevity vision fund and for
our
uh
in your portfolio
one is
gene therapy and gene editing looking
and supporting different technologies
which would bring
more
different technologies to edit or
you know switch on switch off our genes
and
some of that is is literally development
of technologies in some of the cases
it's more like
libraries of viral vectors well it's
serving like an infrastructure for
development of um what we call genomic
medicine so that's that's one thing
second thing is regenerative medicine we
by the way your question is about the
near horizon of longevity innovation
this is how i called in the book these
are all technologies which might not be
fully available today but in 10 20 years
from now
they will be widely available so this is
where the main investment focus of lbf
longevity vision found is so one is
genomic medicine second is regenerative
medicine so
and
in some of the cases we're looking at
uh stem cells
in some of the cases we
um
for example invested in companies which
work on organ regeneration
uh like the example of this company
would be like genesis which used our
lymph nodes to regrow organs inside our
bodies so that's the opportunity to use
one donor liver split it by 50 or 75
pieces and through very simple operation
to put this nucleus in in our lymph node
um
and then in the course of three to six
months the new liver uh grows inside
your body and and um
supports uh the function of the liver
which is not working at the moment so
regenerative medicine like stem cells
organ regeneration etc
we do invest in drug development uh
but it's just very difficult to compete
with big pharma
so i mean it's a huge industry and
they obviously have a lot of programs uh
to tackle that and
well the other problem with drug
development is out of 5 000
candidates right in the beginning of
drug development process
um it's probably one out of five
thousand will make it to the pharmacies
and to doctors and to patients so your
funnel is is um
really against investing into that
because i couldn't really make 5 000
bets right through my relatively small
fund so what we do we invest in
infrastructure for drug development
because if you look at drug development
process today at least in u.s this is
super expensive so it's on average it's
2.6 billion dollars
per drug per successful drug because
you're paying for failures of all the
candidates and it's 12 years process
given the fda regulation and
different trials that you need to do so
um we investing in in in use of
artificial intelligence
to
um
help and with and speed up drug drug
discovery so use of artificial
intelligence in addition to human
intelligence give you an opportunity to
compress the first two or three years
of drug development drug discovery cycle
into two or three months and we invested
in companies like in silicon medicine uh
founded uh by very good friend alex
javaronkov uh or valor health um the
boston based um
founded by david barry from flagship
pioneering this is one of the largest
and one of the most successful biotech
funds they were they actually were
behind success of moderna so
a lot of people uh
knows them that way
um
yeah so that's that's um three
directions the other one is is
diagnostic and and medical devices for
early diagnostic because these days if
you do early like for example cancer
diagnostic your recovery rates uh can be
up to 90 or even 100 percent so cancer
is not a case of that anymore if you
discover that it's very early stage
and by the way recovery rates for late
stage cancer is like 10 20 30 depending
on the cancer type but it's it's still
pretty bad and difficult uh mortal
disease so our idea is to bring
affordable and accessible version of
diagnostic devices and tools um
to
um
you know to the world basically to the
countries that we
we working with so we invested in uh
affordable portable ultrasound devices
uh that are 20 to 40 times cheaper than
the you know huge ultrasound machine
that you have in the hospital next door
we invested in early cancer diagnostic
company called freedom
they based in california and they use um
liquid biopsy like uh our blood test
to identify risk of early stage colon
cancer and colon cancer out of many
cancers is a really difficult one to
identify specifically at early stage so
they developed an almost like a box
product for you to enjoy the um you know
benefit of uh really easy diagnostic of
uh colon cancer and they're working on
other cancer types so that's that's
probably there's something what i call
the far horizon of longevity innovations
which is 25 50 years from now but that's
really futuristic and we don't really
invest in that it's just too early for
us
thank you for that it's really
interesting and yeah i think leading on
from your last point a lot of this
technology in to some extent is still
developing it's very early stage also
also very exciting but then i guess it
makes it a harder decision for investing
as to choosing the right companies to
invest in and making sure that you think
that what they're stating they can
achieve or what they're hoping to do
will actually come to fruition so what
kind of criteria do you take into
account when you choose like which
companies to invest in
um great questions so
one
remember our mission to bring affordable
and accessible version of longevity so
for us the first filter is
is this technology or this scientific
discovery has the potential to be widely
available
to uh the people in the world so that's
that's important for us we're not in the
in the business of investing into
companies which would you know develop
high profile elite treatment which would
cost you know million dollars or pounds
and
so then few people on earth can really
enjoy it so
this affordability and accessibility
aspect is really important so that's one
second thing remember we are investment
funds so we would need to protect um
or help companies that were investing in
protect their ip
so
uh and this is really interesting one so
whatever is in the process of discovery
or in the process of development um
they would have they would have the
uh should have an ability an opportunity
to protect their intellectual property
rights on that uh so that's important
having said that i think
what what was amazing for me to discover
when i started to
spend time and uh invest my time and
efforts into longevity field that some
of the things done by mother nature
uh they also work and and and can be you
know super helpful for our health like
lifestyle changes like a diet changes
physical exercise importance of sleep as
well so
you're always struggling like oh my
goodness this thing work but you know
is it is it going to be like a viable
business
which should you know
always have dollars or pounds to
support the development of this and and
become widely available so
uh the fact that we're investing in this
you know ip protected territories
doesn't really mean that some other
things uh
uh is not working like for example if
you look at the
um
at uh what you can do today and it's
like if you look at my book the science
and technology of growing young
the last chapter is bonus chapter uh
dedicated to 10 longevity choices that
you can do today and almost all of them
you know are for free
or even even if you switch like to the
plant-based more plant-based diet you
actually save a little bit of money from
your family budget so that's that's
in some of the cases that's how easy
it can be to become like a healthier and
happier version of yourself and
meditation is for free you just sit down
in the room
in silence and um you meditate sorry i i
lost the track i got so excited about
this whole thing like what you can do
today that it's very difficult to
bring me to tomorrow what was the
question
i'm sorry sorry i was asking about um
how you made the decision about choosing
companies to invest in okay i got it so
so one is affordability accessibility
aspect
second is about ip uh the third really
is about the team so it's very rarely um
that it's either you know 100 scientific
team or 100 entrepreneurs so it's all
this combination of like bringing the
best of of two worlds the scientific
world and technological or
entrepreneurial world um this should be
there
the fourth i don't know how it's
interesting it's gonna be for our
audience so i would not spend a lot of
time there but like
when you do due diligence and this is
the process of like really you know
doing detailed analysis of the company
before you invest in it um
so for due diligence process you have
like a two or three month maximum before
you decide whether you're gonna invest
in this company or not so this is really
limited period of time so and it's not a
lot of the things that you can check
within this time horizon what we're
looking at is what we call partnerships
what kind of partnerships these people
in these people in this team build to
the whole history of their existence as
a startup or as a team
and we have intentionally broad
definition of partnerships like
their relationship with their employees
and with the tms partnership their
relationship with their investors
is
you know another form of partnerships as
well their relationship or you know
actual collaboration agreements with big
pharma or medical devices companies is
partnership their relationships with
um academia with scientists or with
universities or schools is also
important so we cannot think about this
okay well if this is what they built
this is kind of partnership and
followership that they built through the
years of their development well this is
great then people trust them
they do
really amazing work
and they committed to development of
particular
discovery
or technological breakthrough and so we
kind of happy to be one of their
partners so that's again it's it's in a
very common sense term but it's actually
very important way for us to check like
are we going to be sitting in this same
kind of car
with these guys for uh many years
well no thank you for that and speaking
about your relationship with all these
different companies you've accumulated
through that this huge wealth of
information about not only the the
science but also the technology um of
longevity and also you summarize all of
that information very nicely in your
recent book so i guess my question is
what motivated you to write the book and
what were the key messages that you
would hope someone would take from it
okay beautiful um well one i have three
degrees
so
and i'm always kind of guy who's just
learning learning and learning and
learning so i was at some point of time
i was seriously thinking of do doing
like a fourth degree
and i thought well crazy well sergey you
need to change something in your life
and i thought rather than reading the
books i mean why don't you try to write
the book and it was an amazing time
like this august we published a book
again science and technology of growing
young it's immediately
became best seller it's wall street
journal best seller it's uh
a national bestseller in the u.s um it's
it was number one on amazon in three
categories like preventive medicine
longevity and aging oh congratulations
yeah but so like but like the school the
best
part of it is just actually a book
writing part
because what you do you interview
amazing people and like if you want to
speak to i don't know
like david sinclair or george george or
bob langer the guy behind success and
and foundation of moderna
like it's not a lot of excuses to speak
to them like if you're writing the book
you're going to say look yeah i'm
writing the book you know can you help
me with that and i like of course you
know we're going to help you so it's
been an amazing time like discussing the
future of medicine the future of um gene
editing
gene therapy regenerative medicine uh
drug development
like changes in diagnostic uh or organ
regeneration uh with all these guys i
mean it's been really amazing and uh
i couldn't really share like the old
feelings that you get from you know
inspiration and all these facts and
information from those people obviously
the fact that i'm investor the fact that
i'm supporting scientists and
entrepreneurs would like to make a
change in healthcare sector and and in
longevity technology was like super
helpful so the whole idea was to
summarize and synthesize the knowledge
that we get from looking at 200
companies a year imagine this is just an
enormous information flow plus
views and judgments and experience of
all these you know 50 what i call
longevity pioneers longevity enthusiasts
from all around the world
it's been amazing and uh like the most
difficult part and you probably seen it
in your academic work is actually
cutting out the content so you write
like for the book is like 200 pages it's
not the the biggest book on longevity
but we we literally produce at least 500
pages and like it's always a torture
like to take this part to take out this
piece uh as well but again it's all just
comes down to amazing people that you
you work with um when you work on a book
like
probably two well it was a lot of
memorable conversations but one for me
was uh with martin roadblood
who is amazing woman entrepreneur
scientist uh innovator
who working in the field of organ
regeneration
she is behind a company called united
therapeutics
watch her again such an inspirational
person and the second conversation was
with peter jackson
the man behind lord of the rings uh
avatar um
hobbit uh
movies and to talk with him about the
ethics of longer living and ethics of
human avatars
so that's been
amazing as well so i can only know i'm
like i'm so happy i'm in the end of my
three years journey and book uh was a
success there's not a lot of
undertakings in this life um in in the
world of you know
uh
smartphones then our attention span is
actually around eight seconds like you
know going on three years journey is it
was quite an undertaking but i'm not
really happy it worked out pretty well
that's great to hear i mean it sounds
really inspirational um so talking back
about the content of your book you've
already mentioned
um the way that you break it down into
the the near horizon of longevity and
the far horizon of longevity so speaking
first more about the near horizon and
you mentioned that you yearly go to
something called the human longevity
clinic so what exactly goes on there um
what what happens
yeah so it sounds um like a sci-fi but
it's not it's it's basically
your annual medical screening
and you can do it everywhere in the
world so
it's i just happen to know the founders
of this clinic uh but you go there you
go there and like for the your whole day
is dedicated to
different different different medical
screening procedures okay so
and i'm always saying like the most
important day of your life every year is
the day of your medical screen so that's
uh you know this year for me it was june
8th and i i went to san diego california
for that but all you do is like typical
procedures you do like a blood test
i actually gave like 21 samples of of
blood you do
ultrasound of heart and
this area here uh you do full body mri
and
sometimes you do ct not every year
um you know dexa
so it just it says different like
diagnostic devices and tools that are
available in in any developed country
and
[Music]
for you know all of the people and on
our audience i mean you can check with
your doctor uh
come to him or her
and say look um i just want to be much
more preventive in my
health strategy or health action plan
like what we can do within my like
insurance plan or within what is offered
um
it's okay
uh what we can do within my health plan
or within what um has been offered
to me
to check
against risk of killer diseases which
are cancer heart disease diabetes and
neurogenerative diseases and frankly
speaking there is not a lot that we
understand today about neurogenerative
diseases like dementia
this is rather new for us not a lot of
people before this generation has been
able to live to 80 or 90 years
to face this problem uh but like in
terms of heart uh heart disease diabetes
and cancer
we pretty much know like the whole
medical profession and the healthcare
system knows how to check the risks of
that this is what you need to do um
every year so it's not like it's not
like backhack and clinique which you do
some secret experiments with you this is
really common sense
cool and so i guess you could see these
um these kind of clinics becoming more
prevalent in the future and um i guess
yeah the accessibility for these uh
different uh measurements i guess will
increase as well so i think there's a
stat in the book about
um precision medicine which i guess is a
bit of a segway but being a 200 billion
dollar industry by 2028 i like to meet
20 200 billion even it's a huge number
but like how how big is that number
relative to different industries
oh uh great question i'm not sure i know
the answer but like um
uh
yeah
i don't know the answer you know sorry
uh it's a it's a great strategic
question
uh i've never
never went to such a high level of
synthesis and and being top down yeah
i'm sorry to disappoint you
that's right um i mean to me that that
still is a big number so definitely yeah
i foresee um it being more common that
people do um measure different
biometrics and i guess yeah leading on
from that you mentioned a concept that i
hadn't heard of before which is internet
of bodies so could you explain what that
is
yes um i i can't so
think about my horizons right there's
something you can do right now
right this bonus chapter 10 longevity
choices live healthy it is actually very
important even it sounds boring or
people think it's just lifestyle changes
it is but like uh you know staying on
longevity breach and and so like in 10
20 years from now you can enjoy the
benefit of all these technologies that
we're discussing today so this is now
then near horizon is what we discussed
already 10 20 years from now gene
editing gene therapy um organ generation
longevity and appeal etc so then
looking at the four horizon of longevity
and this is the technologies will be
available to us in 25 50 years from now
there are a number of things so
one is like human avatars
uh you can you know use the robotic
avatar technology or you can use the
technology of virtual avatar right so
for example i'm working in the next 12
months i'm working on a project of
developing a virtual avatar of sergey
yam
so i can speak in so many places right
my mission is to change the world so i'm
not taking speaking fees
so obviously you know i'd like to be
presenting to as many conferences as
possible so you know i'll have like uh
you know it my additional virtual copy
you know who can deliver some of this
picture and it's a lot of fun right
there's not a lot of opportunities for
you to
uh
uh you know hear about seven signs of
longevity revolution from uh human
avatars so what's next and this is your
question like internet of bodies
today we all know the concept of
internet of things
and this is where you know all of the
you know devices around us are
interconnected
and well centrally managed or managed by
you um so then in the future we all
going to be interconnected we're all
going to be full of sensors
and we're going to be part
of decentralized ai run artificial
intelligence run uh network which will
help us to detect any potential issues
with our health and uh not only monitor
but also manage our health on a global
scale so this is the concept of internet
of bodies i'm a little example of it i'm
like full full of sensors today so you
know i have my whoop i have my apple
watch i have my ordering to manage my uh
and monitor my sleep i have continuous
glucose monitor here to monitor glucose
but like in the future they're going to
be
smaller they're more going to be more
integrated with our body and they're
going to be interconnected with
like a number of
centralized uh systems um
what else um is interesting like human
brain ai integration
is super important so we humans we tend
to think so that in the future it's
gonna be fight
between human intelligence and
artificial intelligence i actually think
it's going to be coexistence and it's
actually very typical for humans to
think about the world in contradictory
in like
binary terms like black and white one
and zero
i do believe like we can use the bot of
uh we can use the best of both worlds
and our brains gonna be integrated with
computer power
so we all you know like an advanced
version of humans again
25 50 years from now don't worry about
this one i actually think that
like in in couple of decades from now
the biggest problems with human
advancements and advancement in our
health care
is not going to be in the field of
science it's not going to be in the
field of technology it's going to be
uh
very the barriers we're going to see
it's going to be from human ethics and
regulation because there's not a lot of
people are really excited to like
integrate their brain with computer i'm
also full of fear so we just need to
work on the ethical and and regulation
uh side of it so for us to be much more
comfortable with this technology
thank you yeah that's a really good
explanation and you kind of just alluded
to it that like what are the major risks
with these technologies like either
could someone hack them could someone
steal the data like yeah
um how did you go about that yeah well
that's that's only one but the second
thing well imagine we all interconnected
like what is something you know bad
happening with the world right and like
if we are if we run out of power like
will we retain our ability to
exist in in current biological form
without you know support of you know
electricity powered devices right
yeah great i think it raises so many
interesting questions and that was
another there's the famous charles
darwin quotes which is it is not the
strongest of the species that survive
nor the most intelligent but the one
most responsible for change i think i've
got that right but
like how does um what does that quote
mean to you in the context of all these
advances in longevity
yeah so um
well amazing
and i do think i have this quote in for
one of the chapters um uh in the book so
for me it's like i'm 49
and it's like when you're 49 it's always
temptation like you know i've done three
degrees you know i earned some money you
know i'm father of four
uh kids like
why do i need to start like a next
horizon like a next wave in my life why
do i need to learn this stuff so i'm
like i'm technologically challenged so
i've been like three minutes late on our
podcast because i i really didn't figure
out how to you know manage you know all
these um
uh computers and and zooms as well but
like i push myself every day to do
something which is really uncomfortable
for me
and uh well that's why
you know people feel really
uncomfortable of um
hearing the stories about genetic and
gene therapy like human brain computer
integration but like there is always the
positive use of this
scary or uncomfortable technologies like
i don't know if you watch the movie
called the father with anthony hopkins
it's recently i think yeah like the
whole movie is done through the eyes or
person who's suffering from
dementia
this is heartbreaking movie but what if
we can use brain computer interface to
help people who's suffering from
dementia to spend last few years of
their life and be
assets
not liabilities for their families for
their communities for society well
that's that's like a positive use of
that what's one when people criticize
elon musk with neurolink like i'm always
thinking about
someone who's suffering from
neurogenerative diseases and if we can
use this technology to support him or
her well that's for me like a best use
of it so it's again it's it's always
kind of rethinking like and like frankly
speaking the best you know acid test for
for this is like
if you don't accept something if you're
scared of something and you don't want
to do something well that's you need to
go there right you don't need to change
your life and like dedicate your life to
that but just discover that understand
that and see how this can be of use not
for you sometimes but for you know other
parts of our society this is helpful as
well
i mean leading on from that um
talking more about the as you put in
your book the
morality of immortality um what are the
main
concerns that you think currently
surrounds longevity and living longer
and how do you think we can best solve
them
yeah so
well
it's not even a trillion dollar question
it's it's probably 20 trillion dollar
question which is gdp of uh
us so concerns are um will we have
enough resources like food energy and
like and i'm frankly speaking with
arrival of um
uh renewable energy
sources uh we can solve it
forty percent of food goes to waste
every night at least in the u.s from
supermarkets households and restaurants
so we can redistribute that so i'm not
concerned about this one overpopulation
is is another concern that i hear a lot
and if you look at any study any
reliable study the population of earth
with current reproduction rate
we are in trouble
in demographically so the population of
work will will increase to 10 or 11
billion by 2050 and then it's going to
decrease to 8 billion by the end of this
century so we need to respond to that
right it's not like we'll we'll have a
lot of people on on our for that uh
inequality gap is is a big problem and
uh we need to sort it out so and i i
really hope that longevity and longevity
technology going to be
unifying teams for the nations not um
something which will continue to divide
countries and
and nations and uh people around the
world um
and our relationship with mother nature
like i don't want to live on a planet
which is full of plastic right
uh so
and without biodiversity and that's
that's that's the part which needs
rethinking and revisiting you know all
the time starting from today
yeah many interesting points to take
from that so one of them was um as you
mentioned inequality and and that one
solution is trying to find approaches
that um either are already free or very
like very cheap to do and so one um
thing you have in your bonus chapter is
talking about your subjective age or
psychological aging yeah and i actually
was doing some research last week on
this to make a video and realized that
you have okay written or a few articles
on this so you're a better expert than i
am on it so could you explain what
psychological aging is yeah so like
if you look at research on this number
of studies
in this area which says like
if you actually think that you're
younger
than you are like from your calendar age
your body
supports that and you really becoming
younger and healthier and happier
version of yourself in opposite if you
feel like i'm 49 so if i would like
think about oh my goodness my life is
coming to an end retirement is somewhere
here you know i've done everything i can
do in in this world your body is
actually becoming respond to that and
becoming older and aging processes
accelerate in your body i'm not sure
like 100 how it works because our mind
and and our body
they interconnected um
but uh my mantra since reading that is
like i'm gonna be living to 200 years in
a body of 25 years old man and my body
is sponsored like you mentioned like
every morning i'm waking up and
three-fourth of my life is the head of
me so i'm full of dreams full of plans
and i know like living to 200 is just
impossible today given the current state
of development of science and technology
but like
um it's okay it's a dream to live 200
yeah i'm becoming younger anyway at
least on psychological level and there's
more to it i'm pretty sure you'll you'll
do an amazing video on that um
this is just brilliant like and and and
if you've seen in this
in this bonus chapter like the the whole
story and experiments they've done with
psychological aging they it's just
really mind-blowing how our body uh can
respond to
even like the power of thoughts
in our head
yeah exactly um and so another um issue
i suppose with thinking about living
longer is what is it we're going to be
doing so how do you foresee like the
world of work in the future yeah like i
don't really know like you know and and
it's i i'll give you like very
personalized version of uh response to
this question like
our life will change okay so it's not
like we're gonna be living in the car in
paradigm because what will happen um
robots artificial intelligence uh
computers are gonna be doing a lot of
our work so that's one second we're
going to have universal basic income i'm
i'm truly
i'm i'm really
you know
i'm truly believer in that so
all of us in the future society would
have us you know certain amount of money
to cover our basic needs so we don't
need to work we're going to be an option
but
our definition of work will change right
and it's i don't know if you've seen it
with some of your friends some
colleagues through covet like pre-covet
going to work was like an obligation was
like a torture and like for some of the
people oh i have to work i would just
and then after covert some of the people
say oh my goodness finally i can come
back to my factory or i can come back to
my office and see actual people you know
and and realize myself to work so work
rather than being a liability work an
obligation work will become an asset and
like the opportunity to realize yourself
and it's going to be one of the
activities that we're going to do but
like my mind
and my intellect is not good enough to
even like think through the all you know
consequences of this change but like
it's not going to be the same life that
we're living that's that's yeah i'm
pretty sure
health care you know food uh clothing uh
place to live it's gonna be part of you
know universal basic uh like a mix that
we're gonna receive
uh and the rest is really up to us this
is scary but also it's very exciting
so speaking of work you have um founded
something known as longevity outback and
i was just wondering if you could
explain a bit more about that
so i have found it worth longevity
yes yeah okay so your question is about
longevity at work and um well this is a
program where we transform offices and
factories into more longevity in any
environment and like everything i do in
longevity this is for free so what i'm
doing i'm helping teams all around the
world
to transform their working environment
to
like a healthier version of of that so
we help people to do their annual
screening remember we help people
uh and give them access to
um
to different applications to do smoking
cessation so they they can quit tobacco
smoking
um we are thinking about the safety and
security so you know a lot of people
follow like safety and security
precision to avoid
you know stupid deaths um
we changed the diet and there are
canteens in the vending machines like no
more sugar drinks you know more
vegetables
organic meats and organic fish um
yeah we um
motivate people to use their wearables
and
and go
and do their like 10 000 steps a day
and or we helping them to do like learn
meditation how to meet it
or you know give them a courses about
importance of sleep so all of this is
just really helping them to transform
their life and life of people around
them um
to be more healthier and happier
cool and so for someone who isn't
necessarily a biologist or like a
medical expert and not an investor what
is it that they could do to help the
longevity field right now
um
well
the longevity field is a very early
stage of development
so um the best thing you can do
is to take care of your own health and
the health of people around you
we think about this we delegated all our
health related decisions to other
parties
like doctors which is yeah which is
great so
doctors
well insurance companies
uh big pharma big food in some of these
parties like regulators and governments
some of these parties they have a
conflict of interest because the
commercial organizations right they need
to earn money um and i'm not saying you
need to become your own doctor
but having your voice in this
conversation
uh going on on the discovery journey
to understand the human biology how your
body responds to different interventions
how you can live healthy and happier
life well that's like the best thing you
can do for yourself for your family for
your community for your
corporation organization for your
country and in the world
that's it
like you just need to serve an example
and uh the more people will change their
lifestyle and their attitude towards
health and take responsibility and
control for their own health the better
for all of us
that was really well put um so is there
any other advice that you would want to
leave the audience with um either for
someone wanting to go in the investing
roots or someone more generally about
their health
yeah so um
yeah that's probably i think the key
message from the book we're all going to
be living longer or radically longer
than we expect and that's just and i
want you to start thinking about this
your
health strategy should be different you
should be much more preventive proactive
personalized you should be more involved
because you're going to be hanging out
in this world for like you know at least
couple of decades more than you expect
um
it is about your personal financial
strategy it's about your different
career strategy right can can i have as
many careers
as decades in my life
well it is about family strategies how
are you going to manage all these kids
from multiple generations
you know this
i don't have all the answers and
neither you know
some other people do but
just thinking about this thing about the
implication of longer living and arrival
of digital healthcare much more
data-driven and technology-based version
of medicine it's such an enjoyable
process and i can tell you like this
this whole process and and the whole
change to you about to make your life
has one
huge side effect
you're gonna be healthier
and happier and you really enjoy it
i think you've left us with some really
interesting questions so where can
people go to find out more information
about you
yeah so the easiest way to go to
sergeyang.com
sign up for our newsletters and
the other thing is just
ordering the book
the science and technology of growing
young you can order it from amazon or
any other book platforms
and um yeah and actually when you order
the book and you go to sergeyang.com uh
you can you know claim uh amazing bonus
offer like access to 12 videos called
longevity video academy when i talk
about you know different trends
different technologists and and
interventions that you can do today or
you're going to be
able to do in the future to improve your
health or and receive two other books
one is about the diet diet is really
important in terms of our lifestyle
changes today and uh the other book
about uh
kids health because i'm father of four
so i'm really keen to you know help our
kids to make healthy choices
as early as possible in their life well
thank you very much for coming on again
sergey um your enthusiasm is contagious
and you've covered a variety of
different topics and i'm sure oh i found
myself very interesting to hear and i'm
sure my audience has too so yeah just
thank you
thanks eleanor what i can say you're
doing an amazing job and i want you to
continue to do that this is super
important that we can translate
science and and all these complicated
things in a much more understandable
language uh for all of us and for me as
well so please continue to do this this
is amazing
thank you thank you okay thank you
bye-bye cheers
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you